today I'm going to show you two
relatively more modern games that the
ones that I usually show and these from
the 1995 World Championship between I
should say the Intel World Championship
between Kasparov and Anand they broke
away from philia during those years and
that was played outside of the realm of
fidei and that was really a good
experience I was there for every one of
the games back in 95 that was actually
played at the World Trade Center that
was not there now I'm using I mean
amazingly I should say that the first
game was played on September 4 a
September 11 1995 Game one so it's
incredible
same date six year later six years that
is something so terrible happened the
first date games ended in a draw kind of
disappointing it's like you really
expect more blood but the players were
really feeling each other and it was
very hard to crack they're very strong
players and then all of a sudden came
game nine and a shock Vichy beat Gary
that was really amazing him everybody
was amazed because they thought well
after he held him for eight games
without a loss and now all the sudden
he's leaving one zero is it possible
that he will overtake his crown because
at the time before they the match they
thought it was going to be I would say a
route but it's going to be quite in
Gary's favor and it ended up being in
Gary's favor but that came really came
as kind of a surprise to some people it
was a very nice game I think that it's
kind of under underrated well if you ask
people what are the best games from
World Championships you probably never
see this game I think it has some value
and the game will see right after that
will be Gary's quick response in game 10
where he played a beautiful game he
thought very little because everything
was home preparation and Anand was out
of his theory at some point so at
different stages of the game he was up a
lot of time I think at one time he was
well over an hour ahead in the clock in
a winning position so let's start with
this game first of all this is game nine
and the two players are playing
relatively fast as expected Gary always
played d6 Sicilian and an eye Dorf
inviting a regular night off
he was definitely
the world still is one of the biggest
proponents of the opening and here which
he has of course many many possibilities
and merely decided to play into the
quiet lines after civilian defense
bishop ET ER okay
now Gary can play e5 of course but he
has always believed in e6 very the more
solid the more quiet lines and castles
Bishop e7 a4 again many choices in this
opening are you going to allow black to
play b5 Gary decides not to you could I
mean some lines they play like f4 you
have to do something about the movie 5
but okay again the move order here so
far is pretty flexible knight c6 again
it's a question of taste some people
like to develop the Knight to d7 Gary
decides to hit immediately at the center
the principled move Bishop e3 defending
the knight extra and developing the last
on developes castles f4 so we have the
table of the swelling and defense I mean
this is very very running him variation
everything here has been played many
many times and nothing new Under the Sun
so here Gary played Queen c7 as expected
the Queen always moves and is ready for
some crisis in the center watch what
happened King H won again it's a very
good idea for white to have his King
away from the long diagonal you know
whatever happens later on you can
imagine for example just to give one one
verbal line that I will mention in some
lines after the knight takes here and
the bishop takes here black wants to go
a 5 and immediately get rid of this pawn
for that one if you can
and what happens many times is that the
queen is already on a1 and after a
capture he wants to go Queen to g3 so
for example let me throw a variation and
show you for example if i play for let's
say queenie one immediately instead of
king h one just to show so takes takes
e5 and if white takes takes Queen g3
pinning the pawn to the Queen obviously
you cannot take the bishop
why it looks really really good because
if you go Bishop d6 I can take the
knight on f6 it's pinned upon his pinned
so you'd have to play something said
like 97 then I'm gonna play Knight d5
crushing however black has a very simple
response Bishop c5 because as you can
see the King is on the long diagonal and
the bishop is pinned so the pawn on d5
is no longer attacked and that is
guaranteeing equality that is you know
you can take the knight on f6 then I'll
take on d4 we check it's not nothing to
write home about I'm gonna put my bishop
here so you'll never really kill me with
a knight this is all theory it is all
well known so that has been known to not
really promise that much so King to the
corner very very logical and now Gary
decides to play the move rook e8 again
there are some nuances in this position
that I have to tell you that I don't
really understand like what is the
difference between Ruby 8 immediately or
other moves I'm not not sure that's very
few people understand that the Gaspard
Kasparov is one of very very few that
can really claim that they understand
the opening so for him this is important
so f8 is now cleared for a bishop just
in case you know there's a pawn
advancing their pawns advancing here the
bishop can come to f8 + g6 the bishop
can relocate so yes please to g1 you
mean sometimes there is a very rare move
Bishop Jiwon in some lines of this
variation very rare but definitely I
would definitely not call it a main
reason the main reason is to just move
the King away from the diagonal once and
for all so Bishop f3 again increasing
the pressure in the center and on the
long diagonal making it life much harder
from black to play moves like c6
and the diagonal will open so black
plays to get the principle move Bishop
to d7 now black has it by the way I
should say that in the car Prague has
power of Karpov games you would see a
lot of the move rook to b8 moving the
visible and the rook away from the
diagonal that was back in 1990 that
plays several games
well Karpov was white Kasparov was black
and rook b8 was played again very very
small nuances differences in the
position so Bishop d7 what is the idea
the idea is very simple he wants to play
Knight takes d4 Bishop takes d4 Oh Queen
takes d4 Bishop c6 completing the the
development getting some pressure
against the e4 pawn and again with the
moves roopd 8 and then d5 hoping to
freeze position and just get a decent
game Waypoint doesn't do anything
concrete so again in this position white
plays a move that he really would not do
but in this specific position it's good
and that is to play the move Knight b3
avoiding the exchange he doesn't let him
not the bishop on d7 looks like kind of
a funny piece that was the idea so he's
willing to move is lose the tempo okay
decentralized his Knight also that the
bishop on this seven will look funny
now of course white also has a
positional threat that needs to be
addressed very seriously and that is to
play a five if you allow me to play a
five I have a complete bind on your
Queen side you don't want to do it and
in order to avoid it Black has two
possible moves nowadays you see a lot to
move b6 b6 and the idea is to play
Bishop c8 Bishop d7 costing him time but
again trying to prove that the night is
is upside as well and that is a game
white can play then stuff like g4 g5
Bishop to g2 then try to play for f5 and
again the eternal question what wins
blacks initiative on the Queen side and
trying to hold the center or White's
mobility on the King side in the game he
chose the add other option which is
Knight a5 so he's stopping a farm and
out the knight is both attacked in b3
and also threatening to come to c4 if I
get to go to c4 that's gonna be quite
nice attacking the bishop attacking this
one so why it says you know what let's
get rid of this Knight once and for all
Queen takes and queen d3 very good
developing the Queen connecting the
rooks and extra power against any
chances to play d5 black is dying to
play the move d5 look to what great
length white went to not allow it he has
a pawn a queen and Knight and a bishop
all sitting on the square keeping black
honest very very important so black
plays rook d8 again a very logical move
he wants action in the center he's going
to do anything in his capacity and now
he plays there's a move rook to d1
I believe this ideas by von der wiel
right yeah by Dutch Grand Master John on
the wheel one of the nicest grandmasters
you'll ever meet in your life if you
ever see him very strong in the 80s and
90s he got to play in many tournaments
with Chris Paul because he was invited
to all those Grand Prix event and after
facing Kasparov and having some really
tough time he comes up with a good idea
of rook f d1 again working on the
restriction of the pawn so on e5 white
will play a five again restricting
completely so he plays Bishop to c6 and
now b4 fantastic this is the idea and
this is why the F rook went from f1 to
d1
some of you might wonder hey why don't
you move the other rope over and then
leave the rook on FL for the attack but
there's not going to be an attack today
everything is about the pressure and the
idea was that now the bishop came to c6
before very very nice beautiful little
move basically forcing the Queen away
with a tempo then the bishop is going to
be attack and has to move at a tempo now
if you wonder why can't you be taken
well I think it's pretty easy after you
take here I'm just gonna play rook to be
one Queen is to go to a5 Bishop b6 and
where's the Queen going now out so Queen
c7 b5 very very good and again you think
that now maybe an automatic capture is
in order but that'll be a terrible
mistake
he played Bishop d7 immediately which is
a good move why because if it's a if he
takes on a on b5 takes takes and then
the bishop moves you faked it the very
important a Foursquare for my knight by
taking the pawn will not be here anymore
so takes takes Bishop d7 Knight a four
and I'm already come to are ready to
come visit on B's
first of all with my bishop but then
sometimes with my knight very unpleasant
for blacks point of view you cannot
allow it so he played Bishop to d7 okay
now again a very strong move by white I
moved that I don't know who which which
one of the have a second found he played
rugby one before ninety-two was played
ninety two rook c8 and black got a lot
of a lot of play here so now we have
this map very very interesting once
again we have a slight threat be a six
be a six and then Bishop to b6 securing
the Queen and the rook so he plays now
he can take again I'm not going to
completely bother you with what happens
on on the move rook c8 immediately but I
can tell you that it involves e5 pawn
takes pawn takes now the knight cannot
move because Bishop d7 is not block just
show you that after brooksy85 you cannot
you cannot just ignore me because I've
taken b6 so after takes takes you you
have no good place to move the knight to
and if you move it I'll take on d7 so
the Queen must take Bishop to d4 oopsie
Queen c7 and now Bishop f6 Bishop takes
Queen d7 again one of those lines and of
course black is going to regain his
piece on c3 but you can probably imagine
that once my bishop from the long
diagonal takes the pawn on b7 we're
gonna have some serious mobility on the
Queen side and again the computer says
that this position is just terrible from
luck just on a verge of losing so very
deep games obviously world championship
level so he took and now if you take
with the pawn now I will now go of
course rook to c8 very big difference
there's not going to be a passed upon
anymore
so again Anat sees the difference and he
captures with the mind everything is so
delicate so accurate just beautiful
alright so what to do now here the
comment said Queen a5 was the only move
here to stay afloat and after giving
this pawn
black will take this pawn and again many
many lines I can tell you that here
Bishop b6 is considered to be the best
time white is a little better but black
is still fighting so the line would be
it takes takes takes takes takes takes
and you know slight advantage for white
but nothing nothing too much to bishops
you know and the poem before beef seven
is not going anywhere okay
instead he took and Queen takes rook
takes might have been even better but
this already is kind of a a slight but
permanent edge for white his idea is
very simple he wants to win the b7 pawn
and March is a pawn all the way to the
Queen Square that's my simplistic plan
so of course black is trying to repulse
then if you take a b7 and I take on a4 I
very little to worry about after the
Queen trade so see for saving the C pawn
advancing a five
well again every move you have to count
what will happen if I get to play a five
at some point and E five and the bishop
will take on b7 I mean of course I can
do it immediately but for example Bishop
e6 Queen moves he five and problems
along the diagonal so he tries to shop
both bishops with E 5 and now again not
to take immediately on e5 but to play
here queen c8 if Queen c6 takes takes
and c5 beautiful little move now the
black structure just falls apart the two
bishops now really have a say in the
position now it's really I'm just
wanting to take one point and then take
the other if you take my point I'm gonna
take on e5 and again the night where is
they're not going no place for the 19:09
is going to be trapped in the middle of
the board so this proof just collapses
the black structure just when it seems
like he's attacking a four he is holding
on to everything and comes a move like
this and he's collapsed so obviously
they realized that so he plays Queens
8f takes e5 d take c5 a5 again we can
see that wife is very happy he has his
main advantage right now other than the
pair of bishops space he has a huge
advantage in space that is the problem
so bishop f8 h 3 again such a nice
little move I mean just in case the
knight will ever want to move something
like reposition itself on Knight g4 and
also for the weakness of the last rank
everything is held with one little move
the element of time is not not huge here
Queen e6 trying to activate the Queen
rook d5 a beautiful move by black this
you've seen there are like a million
examples in just in in chess history for
placing a rook where it can be captured
by a minor piece but again when you see
you have two bishops and the pawns are
gonna be moving forward it was amazing
to see that Kasparov bit-bit debate I
was amazed to see that he took that
nobody expected him to take but
something you know he was calculating
something probably he made a either
wrong evaluation or miscalculation I
don't know to today why he did that but
the idea of course is wonderful
well the Brooke is really immune should
not be taken because in the game it was
taking you'll see what happened instead
what he should do is just maintain the
position just be patient for example
they say h5 okay with the double purpose
of a if I ever want to move my knight I
won't be facing Bishop g4 so that stops
that and also an escape square for the
King just a patient that'll move and
again white would have the burden of
showing that he has that he can realize
his positional advantage instead he just
took and they give to question my style
often did you give Kasparov other than
their games if he just blunt and
outright and you give two question mark
that happens to everybody but it's very
rare that you give it through a
positional blunder so takes now look at
those pawns with the two bishops
nothing can stop them now how he did not
evaluate that it's really very
interesting as it says no white just has
to push his pawn that's it it's almost
without effort
nope no I don't remember I honestly
don't remember it just like it's bits
many many years like 20 21 years ago no
but I gotta tell you that if I catch him
in a good moment I might ask him because
it's very very rare it's kind of a
question you don't want to ask someone
at his level because he has so many
billions is you ask him about a two
question mark movies not gonna like it
but you know at the right time
sometime you talk about chess you talk
about at the right moment you can ask
him so queen g6 again c5 very easy to
calculate the pawns are simply moving
forward okay the only chance the only
move to really talk about Bishop e2 very
calmly white basically blocks that black
passed pawn and he is has passed pawns
that cannot be stopped
okay all kinds of moves are possible now
Bishop e7 d6 will be played followed by
b7 and Bishop c7 and I'm gonna take the
b7 pawn so let's see what we're talking
about after here here here and here
I'm not even gonna Queen anything I'm
just gonna take the pawn on b7 and at
the right time a six a seven Bishop b8
buried the rock all my pawns are gonna
move forward terrible so instead he went
rookie five Queen d7 of course last
trick maybe g6 Bishop takes d6 and the
pawn is pinned but of course that's not
for someone like either Arnold Kasparov
to miss and now he played rook g5
yeah if quintic is queen g3 you can even
take the pawn and then you defend the
pawn on g2 with rook g1 easily
there's just no attack and no chances he
tried this and I'm not just played here
III and again one line was to play just
Queen takes b7 rook moves d6 winning
also very easily he decides to go here
good enough
rook g3 now Queen takes b7 Queen e6 one
little cheaper rook takes h3 is
threatened if I can take this followed
by rook I'm gonna win
bye-bye mate or so I don't to tell you
that this is not gonna happen
obviously also if you try to play
something like Bishop g4 trying to
prevent it and then roof takes g4 and if
pawn takes Queen eight-six is too much
but Anand is just unimpressed simply
king h2 the best movement an excellent
move there were still some other tries I
mean they mentioned all kinds of moves
like if rook f1 but I mean there really
other moves like rook d1 was also very
good in Queen d5 the idea is to trade
Queens and there's just no mate anymore
but I think that this is definitely the
funnest move to measure because after
this you just know that this is nothing
and I think he resigned here if I'm were
correctly yeah he resigned here 1-0 he
mentioned some line right if here here
here BAM yep
right exactly Queeny father I'm just
gonna play like d7 and Bishop c7 if I
want to so it's like once Chris power
realized that the last trick failed you
resign so that was the first game that
I'm going to see tonight they should try
game 9 like I said and everybody went
home in great shock the greatest power
of lost in the World Championship and
he's now behind however then came game 2
so this game was really impressive if we
thought that Allen's win was amazing
then this game just came as a it's like
Gary really had to do some work
reminding everybody who's boss it's like
yes I lost the game yes I'm behind 1-0
yes I haven't won anything in the last
nine in the first nine games of the
match but now let me show you why I'm
why I'm playing here it's not buy raffle
that I get my seed so they play again
the Royal appears that they have played
the open Roy Lopez okay this is just
notice that black took on e4 with the
night as opposed to playing Bishop e7
and b5 in casting which is like the
normal classic avoid so d4 again the
most promising move black doesn't dare
take on d4 because rook e1 is gonna
start a disaster so he needs to kick
before the bishop takes the knight here
once again he's gotta realize that the
pawn on d5 is lost
anyway rookie one can always regain it
and he says okay let's make the maximum
d5 very good now everybody takes with
the pawn if you take with the knight
then you allow me to trade knights and
place my bishop on a much better
squirrel in the game I can play on a
long diagonal which the bishop is much
better off than where he has to end up
here so by taking the pawn d5 is hit and
you have to play bishop here that's why
we keep the Knights on the board so
again many many lines have been played
before he played 92 you could also play
Bishop III or Queen e2 and after Bishop
c5 Bishop e3 all kinds of lines he
played here here also normal c3 d4 that
was the main argument that was by the
way also one of the lines that were
played back in 1978 in the famous games
but in a famous match between Karpov and
Coronel
for the World Championship in the
Philippines also you could see many many
moves and like every time somebody
improved the variation and delians
opponent went to the drawing board and
he came up with a remedy and then
another one
I remember at some positions like 94
gallon exclamation mark then the next
game there was a refutation so then he
played a for another exclamation mark
then something was found so in a match
of course what you find on the spot is
like the best the best for the moment
then later on you know can we change so
Knight g5 a beautiful move this is until
today a testing move I think it was an
invention of Michael Tao if I remember
correctly very typical of him it looks
like wait a minute didn't you just move
the knight or where my queen can take it
the answer is yes the Queen can take it
but the thing is when the Queen takes it
I want to go Queen f3 so in the game it
took here but let's examine that if
Queen takes here is a variation Queen f3
I'm getting my piece back that's it I'm
going to play if you play Bishop d7 I
play Bishop d5 and I always have 6 and
this is considered to be a mainline I
think in this position if I recall
correctly block castles and so I mean
this is just a crazy one of those crazy
lines but not everybody's liking it's a
very very testing variation until today
like I always say if we have 4 hours we
can discuss everything however we have
25 min 20 minutes and I have to actually
be out before then so in the game again
that was the discussion pawn takes on c3
pawn takes Knight takes on e6 of course
you have to take away the pawn going
back with the knight is just crazy
and then after we captures Queen to d3
exactly this was the game 6 I believed
that they played also yeah in game 6
this position or arose and 9 f3 was
played ok 93 is is not a bad move per se
it's a decent move but it led nowhere
as you can see Anand was prepared and
the game ended in a draw Kasparov was
not happy with what he got went to the
drawing board or his seconds went to the
drawing board or altogether came up with
a monster' novelty Bishop seat you
fantastic
a fantastic move really a great move
chasing the Queen away listen because
black justification to this position is
that he is gaining space touching the
pole on c3 wanting to take it also in
some lines he won't be interested in
taking the pawn on e5 white want to say
hey I'm cancelled you're not I have two
bishops you don't I have some open
diagonals and lines I'm gonna prove you
wrong and this move really starts at all
now if you just go back with the Queen
again first of all remember I have moved
that Queen f3 which will pin the knight
to the rook and again just like in the
Ella it's gonna be even a worse version
so he does Queen takes c3 again the
computer approves and Knight B 3 very
very strong you think wait a minute
isn't he attacking the rock and after
Knight bTW I can just take it and win
the rock the answer is well when you
analyze everything at home you can do
all kinds of things this is not just a
free rock and now unknown was starting
to consume doodles of time he was kind
of surprised but then by a strong
novelty and he has to figure out a lot
of stuff okay at first he took this move
did after Knight b3 instantly played
Knight takes Bishop takes and now we are
reached we have reached the main
intersection of our game okay in the
game he didn't even dare take the rook
on a1 and here's a variation of why if
he takes it
then check g6 King v7 Bishop takes 6 and
then Queen g4 Chuck is just enormous
enormous so here here the knight is
being hit and after 98 okay again many
many variations I'm just gonna go with
the main line or else we'll sit here
until midnight
rook d1 again what a move to find me now
at home you can take a look and you
don't even bother to take it
and again they mention all kinds of
ideas Queen takes d5 Bishop f4 and then
the Queen takes on a8 after rook b8 the
trying to save the rock Queen d3 the
point of Rogan d1
and Queen d7 checkmate is threatened
huge this is just fantastic
okay again to show the variation I'll do
it to the end he had to sack the Queen
because e 7 was threatened and in this
position again many many movies are
possible Bishop g4 keeping black
completely tied down as possible but ok
this is also ok Wieck is just much
better
obviously the Queen is just way more
active than the two rooks look at the
way the two rooks are so also my pawn
structure is much more healthy I mean I
can always try to pick up those pawns
with my queen so again I'm just showing
you like a little taste you can always
go back and see this game in a database
online or in your own database yes yes
in the mainline weight into b3 what what
is it achieve it's a multi-purpose move
hey I want to get rid of this very
annoying night which is blacks best
piece B I want to be able to develop
this Bishop which is very important for
me as you will see and see I'm defending
my rook temporarily because again we you
saw when you take it I have enough
resources on the light squares so the
best move the computer approves even
today 20 years later the computer still
calls it the best man so after takes and
takes he decided to go the best move
Knight d4 the best try now he took away
Queen f3 in some lines he is still
threatening the rock and he is attacking
the bishop on b3 in some variations so
Queen to g4 again played very quickly by
Gary again like an expected kind of
response he's attacking on e6 with his
bishop and queen of course now Knight
takes b3 Queen takes a6 curtains just
terrible so he took on on you own a one
again he's got a having today he's got a
say me if you don't do that I'm glad
she's gonna play bishop
III next move hit unite twice defend my
rocks and a six is falling so by now
you're obligated to continue but this
variation has been retired because of
this game because of this line Bishop
takes East six again
Kasparov plays a game that's very very
very hard you can see that this is
something that you have to prepare
there's no way you can figure something
like it's over the board
he is down the rook and seemingly
nothing amazing yet that is the spot
although of course he's planting Bishop
d7 check and if the King ever goes to a
dark square Bishop g5 check of Bishop e3
check and the Queen on a1 is lost
so here again Anand plays the best
possible plan he played the move rook to
d8 he cannot take on e6 because I take
and then Bishop g5 is just over if Queen
c3 again check on d7 followed by Bishop
e3 just it's too much
you just can't defend so the route comes
to stop the check on d7 Bishop h6 again
normally when I show this position I
have a lot of time in ahead of me I'm
just learning my class guess what was
the next move because there most of them
will say Bishop g5 but Bishop g5 is not
at all as strong as this next move the
next move is just a monstrous move not
for the sake of winning the g7 pawn or
the rock lucky actually does in the game
but without the pawn on g7 I will be
able to play Queen h5 check with mate
that is the point of this move the
secondary point is that I'm attacking
all your pieces but the main cause of
this move is that I want to take on g7
so if you just don't do anything I'm
going to play Bishop g7 Bishop g7 Queen
h5 check and you made it no because
again I'll always have the g6 pawn to
block any checks on h5 I got a get rid
of this one at all possible
exactly so again a nun plays the best
possible move because again you cannot
sag the Queen for a rock and wind the
bishop because queen h5 check so he's
gotta save the Queen and Queen c3 is the
best possible move so Bishop takes g7
now I'm eyeing the h5 square with my
queen I want to go queen h5 check queen
is f7 mate imagine and again all this
was played very fast by Kasparov
it's like all this he has seen already
already prepared at home
and pour on and this is moved 20 I think
by now at least an hour on the clock or
somewhere around up so he played the
move Queen d3 the most practical move a
I'm if Queen h5 check I'm gonna go Queen
g6 defending against a mate and I have
some ideas of hitting f1 like 92 93
trying to do something but again this is
very very hard to execute as you will
see again Kasparov makes the next move
with no problems
Bishop takes h8 and you think again did
he not see 92 of course he saw 92 black
simply cannot go for it in the game he
went Queen g6 offering a trade of Queens
and he tried to win the exchange we
check no less he would have lost all the
same check check check
again I'm threatening to play the move
Queen h5 check with checkmate
so here Bishop f5 and again there's just
no good moves if Queen d1 trying to
trade Queens I'll just play f3 block the
diagonal if you go to c4 so you can have
f7 then I will just play F for myself
and again the black King just has no
hope here let's say you take I take and
again decisive I can push my F pawn and
my e pawn I'm gonna play Bishop g6 check
and Bishop f6 mate which is the main
threat just completely complete
helplessness
so with this out of the question he
takes and he plays queen g6 offering a
trade of Queens
now you'll be a little surprised because
you think okay all this was so many
fireworks so many meeting ideas and
material sacrifices and in the end white
is just gonna try to win an ending upon
up that's how hard they have to work in
chess so Bishop f6 they could that Queen
trade is inevitable so Bishop e7 again
the most logical move you can just
afford to move the rook away from
civilization he took it and now Queen
takes Queen if you don't take the Queen
now then I will be able to just play
Queen h4 check and I by keeping the
Queen's on the board with your King on
e7 you just have no chance at all if
it's even worse for black so at least
now we're playing an endgame takes takes
and takes now you can say that the
fireworks are done the dust is clear
that the smoke is clear as I should say
and again you see that white has a
bishop against Knight and extra pawn you
think that maybe in this position black
has some chances because of C pawn maybe
can go C 5 C 4 C 3 if he does that he
might indeed get counter chances so
that's why white plays rook c1 the last
hard move of the game the commentators
called a star move that abruptly stops
blacks counter play indeed if c5 would
have been played it would have been a
lot easier for black to defend that
would be something to defend now you
will see that there's no defense of me
sending the F pawn forward so c6 you
don't want to give up the pawn get 7
pawn on top f4 again in many lines I
suggested if Luke g8 just simply bishop
d1 and again it's gonna be very very
hard to play
he played a5 trying to do something on
the Queen side where he has some
advantage King F 2 a for King III the
King comes to the to the game before
Bishop d1 again a very accurate move
really really nice for example a
tempting move here would be to play the
move rook c4 which hits everything
it hits d4 tickle c6 hits before but
after rooks c4 simply a3
and of course now very very annoying you
can't take the pawn because of the fork
this is protected and of course you
can't even dream about taking the night
because after takes takes b3 and one of
the black pawns makes a queen so again
once again they just like in the
previous game those of you who are here
it's incredible to see how you can build
such a beautiful game and one little
slip and you're being punished but at
the highest double that rarely happens
so he plays again bishop d1 immediately
putting the question to the pawn hey
three
yeah b3 i just take and if you play a
three I just keep pushing Mike inside
pawns it just you don't win your pawn so
a 3G for enabling the move f5
the rest is very very easy route d5
rooks c4 now c5 okay if neither five
check is also no solution because I just
take it and of course the rook ending
with the massive mess of pawns going in
the King side is just too much c5 King
e4 row here
rook takes e5 again b3 just Bishop takes
b3 and I'm stopping the pond easily with
my own pieces so 96 rook g5 again a
beautiful move you're attacking my rook
you're attacking my bishop on d1 and you
want to play rook default check I kill
all those with one move so row here of
course you cannot trade and win on f4 I
go King c4 and I win all your Queen set
pawns on top so here f5 rook c4 check
King III if King d3 rook c3 is just not
not the point Knight c v g5 beautiful
back asparagus just like really a
perfect game pad basically look to see
one
rook to d6 and in this position undone
resigned there's just no defense against
f6 and then e 6 is protected so my main
threat is f6 and then Bishop h5 and the
king is going to be mated on da
basically there's no defense complete
and utter demolition by Gary beautiful
game okay guys this was it thank you for
coming for my lecture to my lecture